The specific objectives
of this lesson are,
one, we will really learn how to
generate a panorama, building on
the ingredients that we have actually
spent a lot of time on until now.
We will actually revisit
the concepts of image re-projection.
We will learn about homography
between the two images.
Basically, looking at two images and
how we can compute the homography.
They'll let us do both the alignment
of images and registration and
also kind of learn about how
we combine those images.
We will also learn about things like
how do we actually find points and
reliably detect them as
inliers versus outliers.
And then finally, I'll actually discuss
some of the, specific aspects of how we
construct panoramas and
our ideas of different types of things.
Again, something we've touched on.
So again, the goal here is to bring
all of those concepts together and
show you how we can actually do
something like panorama building.